hola bienvenido al vídeo de biología
esencial número 20 que trata sobre
factores bióticos y abióticos lo primero
que quiero hacer es definir estos
términos bióticos significa vivo así que
para revisar los factores bióticos vamos
a ver todas las cosas vivas que pueden
afectar a las poblaciones oa los
organismos y los factores abióticos son
las cosas no vivas o que no tienen vida
así que déjenme darles un ejemplo de
cada uno de ellos en 1995 los lobos
fueron reintroducidos en el parque
nacional yellowstone estos fueron los
primeros lobos que fueron llevados
dentro del parque
en realidad estuvieron cercados por un
tiempo porque no querían que se
regresaran a canadá y esto sería un
factor biótico añadimos algo vivo a un
ecosistema al parque nacional de
yellowstone esto es un factor bióticos y
un factor abiótico aquí tenemos una
gráfica del dióxido de carbono
atmosférico se ha estudiado la cantidad
de dióxido de carbono en la atmósfera
por los últimos 50 años probablemente
has leído sobre esto y podemos ver que
el dióxido de carbono se ha incrementado
en estos últimos 50 años
esto está causando el calentamiento
global la temperatura se está elevando
más y más ahora la temperatura no es
algo vivo así que lo consideramos como
un factor abiótico estos dos factores
bióticos y abióticos van a afectar a los
organismos las poblaciones y ecosistemas
y esto es lo que queremos tratar en este
podcast el punto es que quiero hablar
sobre estos factores abióticos y
bióticos factores vivos y no vivos y la
forma en que causan interacciones entre
células el ejemplo que les daré son los
biofilms que en español también llamamos
biopelículas y esto como resultado de
los factores abióticos y a nivel de
organismos voy a hablar sobre las
relaciones entre depredadores y presas y
como un organismo puede afectar las
poblaciones de otro organismo y
finalmente en un nivel mayor a nivel de
ecosistemas de poblaciones y comunidades
voy a mostrar cómo puede estar
interconectado un ecosistema y como en
las redes alimenticias un pequeño cambio
en una red alimenticia puede tener
grandes repercusiones en toda la red muy
bien quiero empezar por el nivel de
células como los cambios en los factores
pueden afectar las células y el ejemplo
que quiero darles son los biofilms es un
término con el que mucha gente no está
familiarizada pero en realidad nos
afecta más de lo que pensamos los
biofilms están formados por bacterias y
si tenemos bacterias tendemos a llamar
las bacterias trans tónicas lo que
significa que están flotando y
moviéndose por ellas mismas pero si en
algún momento las pones en un ambiente
en donde haya una superficie a la que se
puedan unir y luego puedes tener un
flujo en general y el flujo del líquido
va a ir en esta dirección
así que si alguna vez tienes un flujo de
líquido y luego una superficie a la que
se puedan unir las bacterias forman algo
que se llama bio film así que si estamos
hablando de alguna superficie a la que
se puedan unir flujo o al menos algún
líquido estamos hablando de factores
abióticos
y cómo van a ser afectadas las bacterias
bueno las bacterias van a empezar a
formar un biofilm así que esta es una
bacteria por sí misma pero una vez que
se empiezan a unir producen un limo
alrededor de ellas que se compone de
diferentes macromoléculas una grande
serían los polisacáridos pero
esencialmente lo que hacen es que
empiezan a formar una capa de limo
alrededor de las bacterias y una vez que
tienes esa capa de limo alrededor de las
bacterias puedes desprender algunas de
esas bacterias que se vuelven
planctónicas y es realmente difícil
deshacerte de biofilm es un ejemplo de
biofilms sería la placa que se forma en
tus dientes simplemente no puedes
deshacerte de ella físicamente tienes
que raspar ahora tal vez no parezca tan
malo pero algo que probablemente va a
afectar tu vida serán las heridas así
que estamos empezando a imaginar que
heridas crónicas y los sitios crónicas y
cosas como esas son causadas por
biofilms esas son bacterias que en
realidad se construyen una casa de
protección alrededor de ellas y lo que
hace que de miedo es que normalmente
tratamos las bacterias con antibióticos
y si aplicamos antibióticos
y no le hace nada no pueden alcanzar las
bacterias que viven en el interior y así
los biofilms son una respuesta de vida a
la interacción con factores abióticos es
decir a una superficie y a un líquido
que fluye enseguida quiero hablar de
cómo los organismos pueden afectar otros
organismos esta es la relación
depredador presa y probablemente la
relación depredador presa más famosa
cuando estudias biología es la relación
entre la liebre americana y el lince
canadiense los dos viven en canadá o en
el norte de eeuu y lo interesante de
esta relación es que el lince canadiense
se alimenta de liebre americana y lo
único que puede atrapar una liebre
americana es un lince canadiense
entonces están relacionados en este
ciclo donde la población de liebre
americana afecta al lince canadiense que
a su vez afecta a la población de liebre
americana este es un estudio de 1937
mcgillis pero lo que ellos estaban
observando eran las pieles de la
compañía hot zombie
esta es información desde 1800 hasta
1930 y lo que pudieron hacer es
aproximar las poblaciones
americanas y de linces canadienses a
partir del número de pieles encontradas
de estos dos animales y lo que puedes
encontrar es que la población de liebre
americana va de arriba a abajo y luego
sigue de arriba abajo y va de arriba a
abajo y hace este ciclo
y veremos este patrón muchas veces
especialmente en poblaciones que se
reproducen rápidamente como roedores y
conejos
pero lo que es interesante es que si
observas la población de liebres
americanas cuando esta población de
liebres americanas empieza a crecer
entonces podemos ver que la población de
linces también se incrementa porque
sucede esto bueno porque los linces se
alimentan de liebres y entonces cuando
la población de liebres se incrementa
pues hay muchas liebres y los linces
canadienses pueden sobrevivir y pasan
sus genes a la siguiente generación y de
esa manera la población de lince se
empieza a crecer y luego cuando la
población de liebres disminuye entonces
la población de linces también disminuye
porque ya no hay más fiebres para
alimentarse y entonces la población
disminuye y si trata de trazar esto
pueden ver que hay una relación de
depredador presa ahora muchas veces no
podemos ver esto en la naturaleza y la
razón por la que esto sucede es que hay
muchas otras cosas que también se
alimentan de la población de presas pero
si nos fijamos en esto podemos ver como
la población de depredadores se desplaza
un poco hacia la derecha pero responde
con claridad a esto ahora qué tipo de
factor es este estamos hablando de un
factor
en otras palabras el factor biótico que
es la población de liebres está
afectando la población de linces
canadienses y viceversa ahora de nuevo
no siempre es tan sencillo especialmente
conforme subimos en los niveles
ecológicos entonces ahora estamos viendo
a niveles de poblaciones ecosistemas y
comunidades y lo que encontramos es que
hay una red alimenticia compleja y los
cambios en esta red alimenticia pueden
tener enormes repercusiones en el
ecosistema
por ejemplo los lobos fueron eliminados
del parque yellowstone fueron cazados
por los humanos para deshacerse de ellos
porque tenían un impacto enorme sobre el
ganado en el número de vacas se
alimentaban de vacas así que los
ganaderos se deshicieron de ellos en
realidad el gobierno se deshizo de ellos
en el parque yellowstone y de que se
alimentaban los lobos además de vacas se
alimentaban de siervos y qué pasó con la
población de siervos la población de
siervos aumentó ahora sería difícil
imaginar qué pasó como resultado de esto
quiero decir tal vez quieras saber cómo
fue afectada la población de coyotes de
zorros rojos
de castores de sauces de álamos como les
habrá afectado bueno déjenme decirles lo
que sucedió realmente como la población
de ciervos aumentó los ciervos se
alimentan especialmente de álamos
jóvenes y de sauces la población de
sauces disminuyó y también la población
de álamos disminuyó y como resultado de
esto los castores fueron eliminados del
parque yellowstone porque ellos se
alimentan de álamos y sauces y qué pasó
con la población de coyotes la población
de coyotes aumentó porque los lobos en
realidad matan coyotes los ven como
competidores como la población de
coyotes aumentó y no podían alimentarse
de ciervos porque simplemente son muy
grandes tuvieron un impacto muy grande
en la eliminación de muchos ojos rojos y
lo que pasó fue que esto estaba fuera de
flujo todo esto como resultado de la
eliminación de lo que llamamos una
especie clave entonces qué pasó desde
que introdujimos lobos en el parque
yellowstone la población de ciervos tuvo
un descenso dramático como resultado
vimos un incremento en estos un
incremento en estos
y un decremento de la población de
coyotes así que estamos hablando sólo de
factores bióticos y qué pasó con los
castores bueno los castores construyen
presas y eso impacta el flujo del agua
para que fluya más lentamente y que se
formen estanques eso ahora es un factor
abiótico y así podemos ver como una sola
especie puede tener enormes
repercusiones en el ecosistema va a
afectar factores bióticos va a afectar
factores abióticos y en realidad va a
cambiar incluso en el nivel de
ecosistema va a tener profundos cambios
especialmente cuando retiramos un
depredador grande esto está bien está
mal
bueno el parque yellowstone ha regresado
a un equilibrio entonces cuál es la
respuesta correcta
probablemente no haya una respuesta
correcta los globos probablemente están
aquí para quedarse pero esto nos muestra
la complejidad de la vida cómo es que
está interconectada y cómo los cambios
en un área pueden afectar a las
poblaciones y estos son factores
abióticos y factores bióticos espero que
esto haya sido de utilidad